my name is nicole russell and i'm on a
quest a quest to become the greatest
pizza maker in the world
[Music]
last season i sharpened my skills with
the best oh my gosh the piece is on fire
i have made a pizza dough out of flaming
hot doritos you close your eyes and boom
you go to naples but now i've enlisted
two of my friends to help me take my
pizza powers to the next level every
episode frank pinello and josephine
giordano will be challenging me with a
new pizza themed competition gonna be
making pizza fritta pineapple pizza cast
iron pizza i'm actually going to do my
best at replicating domino's pizza i'm
making my personal favorite pizza hut
supreme and once again i'll be facing up
against some of the world's best pizza
makers and internet chefs you're facing
off against the heavy hitter nick d
giovanni georgia from don antonio
benjamin with fish nicole you think you
could beat him i gotta beat him all for
a chance to take home the coveted golden
pizza trophy this is delicious oh my
gosh i gotta top this you like it i love
it
we're gonna have to talk this over yo
it's so hard to get past these two i'm
telling you i started my journey cooking
pizza out of my home kitchen in queens
but this year i'm on a mission to open
my first brick and mortar restaurant in
manhattan and i know frank and joe can
help me add a few new tricks to my
arsenal of pizza creations first we
feast complex we're a pizza family do we
get to eat this now do i get to put this
in my mouth yeah i'm gonna give you some
so get ready for more cheese more sauce
more dough and a whole lot more pizza i
out piece up the hut you are the queen i
gotta put money in my pizza
no more trophies only money pizza wars
is back
[Music]